sur une somme barre amel bent et son
partenaire christophe licata est oui
et
[Musique]
j'aime pas la même silhouette là
samba
vous êtes sublime évidemment entre
jennifer lopez et beyoncé chacun son
école évidemment c'est danse avec les
stars 6 3 et ce fameux christophe licata
vous dites il ya un avant et un après
christophe licata et s'est vraiment
passé quelque chose sur le plan physique
sur le plan de votre regard sur vous
même avec les pollutions mais de toute
façon moi j'ai eu trop de chance parce
que j'ai fait 2 2 émissions important de
faire trois émissions de télé importante
dans ma vie c'est la nouvelle star donc
ça a quand même été le début de ma
carrière
the voice cas pour moi qui m'a appris
tant de choses sur moi même si je pense
que ça m'a appris à beaucoup mieux
verbaliser tout ce que toutes mes
pensées à devoir voilà vraiment mettre
des mots sur ce que je ressens de
manière concise
voilà ça m'a appris à parler un peu
mieux et danse avec les stars entre les
deux évidemment je je je pense que je ne
pourrais je ne je n'aurais pas été la
même femme je pense que par exemple je
ne sais même pas si si si même mon
histoire d'amour avec le moment mon
amoureux depuis neuf ans maintenant
réexister si j'avais pas rencontré
christophe un an avant pendant danse
avec les stars il a
je sentais que je devais grandir mais
c'est à dire me révéler en tant que
femme en fait mais adultes en fait
j'avais un côté très enfants avec un
rapport à mon corps qui est trop spécial
que j'assume et pas
j'étais pas à l'aise j'ai été il y avait
les complexes évidemment beaucoup qui
avait disparu et pourtant je vivais
toujours dans dans che pas un peu
enfermé dans mon corps c'était trop
bizarre je ressentais sur scène parce
que chez moi je faisais plein de choses
je dansais dans ma chambre et tous et
puis dès qu'il fallait devant le public
se présenter
voilà j'ai un truc qui allait par et
tout le monde me faisais la réflexion et
c'est dommage que tu bouges pas assez
mais c'est même pas le fait de danser 1
c'est une façon de marcher c'est une
façon de se tenir s'il ya quelque chose
qui était pas qui était pas fini